we
are live david pakman good morning from
new zealand sir
thank you you're doing well doing well
uh afternoon here you know another
another normal day in american politics
which is
you know a crazy day really in in boston
is that right we live up in boston
that's right um
i have to pick a bit i got a bit of bone
to pick with you actually because
you may you just made me watch about 40
minutes of that orange orangutang
talking in a monotone voice to
workers although i have to say people
who don't know i was watching the end of
your live stream
do you know at the end of your
livestream how you turned off because
there was music playing did you pick up
on what that music was
i think it was ymca
the most impressive gay anthem the world
has ever known
playing at a trump rally in front of a
whole lot of uh hairy masculine uh
texans i laughed and laughed and laughed
so loud
so i'm glad that you uh accidentally put
a little bit of that over i thought that
was
utterly hilarious yeah it's um
it's a a real exhibit in uh
confusion yeah the way i describe a lot
of these events i was like he obviously
knew his audience or maybe he didn't or
maybe he never does
to play that particular song it was very
funny
hey um i don't think he's that involved
honestly in a lot of these details you
know i think he just shows up and
you know he often struggles to even read
the script that's handed to him so i
think he's
minimally involved in the details has he
been good for you
meaning numbers streams memberships that
sort of thing
if you personally obviously not the
country i mean listen
any time that there's an election it's
it's a good year
for me so that's that's always been the
case there is no doubt
that since donald trump was elected so
many
more people that were not paying
attention to politics in the u.s
started paying attention for good
reasons in the sense that they perceived
that
their lives maybe more so than in the
past
were going to be directly affected by
things that this administration was
planning to do or
would stumbled into one way or the other
right so that's great
and then yeah i mean i've said to my
audience i think that if joe biden wins
in november
it would not be as good for my business
but it would be better for the country
so i'm still voting for biden i've been
transparent with the audience about that
i was listening to something you were
saying the other day and you were
talking about
um kind of the left uniting it's time to
unite because
even though there are some things that
the left disagrees on uh you know
the the the big thing everyone agrees on
is getting trump out so
the smaller things you're arguing about
put aside for the next three months get
trump out and pick up the conversation
again
um i was thinking about that and i was
thinking
i wrote a piece maybe six months ago and
funnily enough you used the phrase
burning down the house when you're
talking about it
about the the the whole system needs to
be burned to the ground
and someone like bernie would be
starting to rebuild it with new wood
and someone like biden would be starting
to rebuild it using all the charred
pieces of wood on the ground
and i was just thinking the one thing i
felt like not that you left out that i
was thinking that wasn't the part of
that conversation you were having
was at some point we all go i can't do
this anymore
i can't do this at some stage i have to
say enough is enough
and everyone has that at a different
place
and for people who are probably let's
say center left to left they haven't hit
that yet
but it would seem that those who may be
on the far left they have hit that
and that's why they want to burn that to
the ground and at some stage everyone
will hit that wall
and obviously you know wherever you
place yourself in politics on that
continuum you haven't hit that yet but
at some stage you will
if things don't change and that's i
thought was the one thing that was maybe
left out of
the conversation was when we say let's
just more or less i'm not involved but
everyone gets together and elect
trump what about those people who have
hit the wall and have gone even electing
biden's not going to change anything
like obama was supposed to bring hope
and change and there was a lot of things
that didn't happen there
what would you say to those people well
there's a there's a lot of different
things in there so let's explore some of
them
it it's certainly possible that people
have a different
breaking point i mean sure the breaking
point for one person is different than
the other
but that sort of implies that
it's just a difference of opinion this
idea of
incremental change versus burn it all
down and try to
build it build it back up so to speak
the case i've made
is that if you look at the sort of
modern american political era of the
last 140 years
burn it down to build it back up just
has not worked yeah if you actually look
at the big movements that have achieved
change you look at the progressive era
of 1890 to 1920
you look at the post-world war ii new
deal era
and then you look at the 60s late 50s
into 60s civil rights era
really it's the ideology of i like to
say of martin luther king
rather than malcolm x that has actually
achieved change which is
right having the right people in the
supreme court for example because so
much ends up coming down to that
burn it down to build it back up won't
achieve that at least it hasn't
um when you look at voting rights in the
10s and twenties
when you look at so much of of of the
new deal era i mean
my argument is sure everybody can have
what feels like a breaking point and we
can disagree about what that is
but if you look at the three big areas
times of progressive advancement in the
united states
they've come from having the white house
and having the right people in the
supreme court and having a house and
senate that are on your side
and so i'm making an empirical case
rather than
you i'm not disagreeing with the
emotional case you're making
at some point everybody will hit the
wall but i try to make it a more
empirical case if that makes sense
does that therefore scare you about the
um
well scare that's an emotional response
uh give you pause for concern
about the supreme court um because if
you need the supreme court
with you know the republicans stealing
uh a justice from obama and then putting
a few in
and now you know ruth bader ginsburg
being ill again and everyone just going
please hold on please oh
please hold on um that that might take
decades to get to where let's say
someone who's further left
progressive wants to get to because of
the new appointees that have just
just happened yes so
there were actually some people
on the left i mean i i don't want to say
ostensibly on the left like
okay they're on the left but they have a
different approach than i have
who in 2016 were saying i'm paraphrasing
if it's not bernie hillary trump you
know it's kind of all the same
yeah but if we've learned anything in
the last three and a half years
it's that neil gorsuch on the supreme
court
uh kavanaugh on the supreme court this
has had a real impact
hillary clinton would not have selected
them sure maybe hillary clinton would
not have selected someone equivalent to
bernie sanders okay
but there's for me one of the great
vindications has been or the great
lessons
has been those people who were saying if
it's not bernie it's sort of all the
same
yeah yeah it could not have been more
wrong yeah
that's a it's a it's a really good point
and i and i guess
although i was thinking yesterday i read
a story about how kavanaugh
is going around at the moment going
around i'm talking to his fellow
justices about
not kind of putting the um the tax
records in front of the
supreme court trying to um convince his
counterparts not to put that in front of
the supreme court
to me that also says maybe the system's
still working either under those
justices
because maybe he's what he's saying is
if it comes in front of the supreme
court we're going to have to open them
up
and if that's the case that means even
though he's a right-wing justice well a
conservative justice the justice system
is still working under the supreme court
sure i mean i think it's a bit
speculative and and
i don't pretend to have any idea i mean
from what we've seen in terms of
decisions from this
court over the last few months i don't
find
too much i don't think i'm particularly
adept at predicting how they will decide
on any particular case
so certainly we we could speculate about
that but
you know when you look at holding that
seat open that
should have gone to merrick garland
during barack obama's last year
and consider for a second if there were
to be a seat open
between now and january would
republicans take the same approach and
say you know
or between now and november maybe is a
better better analogy
we should wait because trump might lose
of course not and that
argument was always you know political
bs and posturing and if we've proven
anything it's that
they don't care about consistency
hypocrisy is irrelevant double standards
don't matter
yeah and we have to really buckle down
and you know this was what was so
frustrating not to change topic but
during the democratic primary when i
would see people kind of messing around
with
the one percent candidates a little
too deep into the primary where the
stakes were starting to get clear
and it was pretty clear who who was sort
of in the thing i always want as many
different voices to be
at least on the table but once it
becomes clear
sort of who are the choices and the
people continuing to call me late into
the game
saying someone pulling one percent
that's who we should get behind and
they're the only person who can defeat
trump
it started to feel a little bit like
2016 and it was it was i'm glad that it
sort of wrapped up when it did
were you surprised i mean not to
relitigate what's happened i mean
when everyone got behind joe biden in
the space of like 48 hours after a few
phone calls from obama
that was one of the most amazing
political events
i think i've ever seen because it did
look like bernie all the way through
at that stage again as i say not to
relitigate it i'm not interested in
doing that but
as a as a political event that
48-hour window was unbelievable
yeah so two sides to it one as an
undertaking it was incredible what was
done
i mean you know when you looked at the
numbers i actually disagree that it was
that clear that it was going to go to
bernie but i'll talk about that in a
moment but
certainly at a superficial level to see
i mean the momentum changed 180 degrees
yeah there's no question about that
so as an achievement whether you like it
or not and a lot of people don't like it
and certainly biden is not
the progressive panacea that anybody
would would like to see if
that's your your politics as an
accomplishment in the political space
in a 48 to 70 hour period incredible
incredible
now i remember uh the south carolina
primary which was the first one that joe
biden won was on a saturday night and i
was
out with some friends so i didn't see
the results
and i think around midnight or so when i
got home
i saw oh joe biden won south carolina
and he won it
very easily the results didn't surprise
me
but i thought this is a big momentum
shift
because very often you hear these things
like
when we get a primary that is more
diverse
things are going to turn around and then
like everybody repeats it and it never
happens and it's just like okay i guess
that wasn't true
yeah south carolina was the first
primary that was not
overwhelmingly white you had iowa and
new hampshire
and it was exactly as predicted joe
biden was polling really well with with
black americans bernie sanders was not
joe biden easily won south carolina you
saw the map
you saw the list of upcoming primaries
so i was not
that surprised with the turnaround i
thought that it was notable
in in how it happened um but it i did
there was no point where i
said i can't believe this is happening
it made sense based on
looking at the demographics and looking
at the poll
yeah it's it's gonna be i
we have a similar situation in new
zealand but it's sort of reversed like
at the moment our
um government our labor government which
is
so to explain it to people who are
tuning in from from your side we have
five parties in government
two major parties who are akin to um you
know the the republicans the democrats
although we are much further left there
was an article
in one of our papers the other day that
said the center left is the new center
in new zealand but we basically have go
uh to make it easy although
i'm expediting it for the sake of
conversation
uh far-left green party a left labour
party a centrist new zealand first party
a right national party um
and then a far-right act party now three
of those parties only make up maybe
15 of government the other 85 percent
has made between the two the two big
parties
um and we sort of have the reverse at
the moment that we have
a 60 to 65 percent um support
for our incumbent government um
left-wing government basically based
around what's happened with coronavirus
but i've been thinking and we have a
different style of uh
electioneering that's called mixed
member proportional which basically
means
every vote counts uh when you vote for
the party you get to vote for the party
so you might vote for labor or for
national but you also get to vote for a
local
politician for your area as well so you
get two votes
but the party vote is the only vote that
really matters
because that's the percentage that they
base the number of mps on members of
parliament on
so anyway even though we're a 60 party
and we being the current government not
me
um i was still thinking when
people get into that booth and they have
to put the x on or pull the lever or
push the button or whatever
however it's done i'm interested to see
what will happen on the day
and it's a bit similar for america even
though biden seems to be on a national
scale and i know you've been
kind of talking about this no don't get
complacent go out and vote
when they actually get in that booth
maybe those independents maybe those
moderate republicans
and they have to actually pull the lever
for joe biden or stick with maybe
republican over trump what will they do
and i wonder if it's going to be
both new zealand and america
closer than has been predicted at the
moment
well i think there's no way you know
there's some polls that have biden up 13
or 15 nationally
i i don't think there's any chance that
happens so
i think it is going to be closer and if
you could argue this is a different
situation this is an unprecedented
situation but typically
as you get closer to election day
undecideds break for the incumbent
and um i don't knows break for the
incumbent
turnout often will will break for the
incumbent
slightly i think that's what happened in
2004 when it looked like maybe john
kerry could defeat george w bush and of
course it
didn't end up working out that way so
joe biden's not going to win
the popular vote by 15 or by 17 i don't
think he'll win by double digits
but in the electoral college you could
really have a very lopsided
situation now there's another sort of
component to this
that's being discussed here which is the
idea of a shy
or embarrassed trump voter right that is
not
admitting their support for trump right
um
i don't believe it and and it's not i
have no
special insight but i've read a bit
about this
first of all you know a lot of the
polling right now is is automated you
get a call on your cell phone and you
press a button indicating who you
support
there's no real reason that in that
situation
one would be shy about saying they are
supporting donald trump i mean
they're essentially anonymous so in that
situation it doesn't
strike me as something that's
particularly likely
there's the idea that for strategic
purposes trump voters
thinking ahead might say you know if it
looks like biden's winning
more trump voters will be motivated
right and so
i'm going to say in the poll that i
support biden even though i really don't
i've seen no evidence i mean you know
the way that the polling is done you
you'd really need a sort of concerted
effort of people to do that and we would
have heard about it so i
i don't think that's the reason why
it'll be closer than the polls say
i think the historical reasons explain
why it will be closer than 10 or 13 or
15. yeah
yeah under our new zealand system called
mmp mixed member proportional we've
never had a majority government
so that's been in place since about 1994
and we've always had a minority
government and um which basically means
for people who are uninitiated
no party has ever got over 50 so you've
had
had to have a coalition of parties to
get over 50 to become government so at
the moment in party
in government we've got the labor party
i don't know what their numbers were but
let's say they're on 35 percent of the
vote
we've got the greens they've got 10 of
the vote and we got new zealand first
which is that centrist
party which maybe got six or seven
percent of the vote making up let's say
52
via the government the largest party is
labor that's where the prime minister
comes from
jacinda ardern and uh every new
zealander well once
every new zealander every sane new
zealander thanks to lucky stars
under this covert crisis that this is
the government we've got and she is the
person leading it because
yeah i mean so yeah i've said
i've said here in the us that you know
when there's a big crisis a real
national crisis 911 for example katrina
although that was bundled pretty quickly
so it didn't really happen but
with nine and 11 there was this rally
around the flag effect where george w
bush's approval rating shot up into the
high 80s the highest it had ever been
he ultimately squandered it by attacking
iraq which had nothing to do with 911
and the rest is history
early in coronavirus donald trump's
approval actually went up
then we know what happened you know so i
don't i don't have to tell the story
and now he's facing you know an
embarrassing electoral defeat
maybe we'll see sort of what happens
i've argued that had he handled
coronavire as well which really by that
i mean defer to the doctors
come clean up front that this is a
difficult time for the country and we
need to band together there will be
difficult times but we will come out on
the other side i've argued that he would
be staling towards re-election of course
in new zealand is it your
belief or instinct that jacinda arder
now
is experiencing the high levels of
approval essentially for the opposite
reason that
she did really well with the virus yeah
yeah no absolutely that's 100
100 that's what's been going on i mean
um she was a popular prime minister
anyway
she was in she was our prime minister at
about 38 she just turned 40 in the
weekend so she's young she's vibrant
she's engaging she has
a different style of management and in
her first
term one that may not be quite
known so well around the world is we had
a volcanic eruption
in new zealand called fakadi white
island facade is maori named for it
um and it went off and people died and
people got
you know very badly damaged from that
that happened in her
familiar with it okay we had a
christchurch massacre
which we've never seen before we don't
own guns well we
we're farmers but in new zealand like
you can't just go to the shop and buy
again it's a very different culture
we had a massacre where 51 muslims died
unheard of in this country um and we had
the the covert crisis all these things
have happened
during jacinda ardern's reign and she
had a baby
in her first year as prime minister so i
think she was already kind of
i don't say put on a pedestal but it's
pretty easy to make someone who's gone
through those things
popular you know just look at them and
look at them with admiration
uh when john key who was our previous
prime minister he was a more of a
right-wing
prime minister although i'm hesitant
using those terms
um to an american audience because our
right-wing
politicians voted for same-sex marriage
and they voted for
many left-wing policies like
interest-free student loans and working
for family which is a tax break
if you've got kids so when i say right
wing it's very different from perhaps
what an american might think when when
they hear right wing
but we had the christchurch earthquake
under john key
and he saw similar levels of um you know
uh people are proving of him how
he handled the the christchurch quake so
yes absolutely because of covert that is
one of the reasons
that jacinda is riding so high she was
pretty popular anyway
but i i have to be honest i'm i'm
sitting in dunedin
so that's the bottom of the south island
you can't go much further south than
where i am basically next year
antarctica
um and i'm out there every day
dressed like this no social distancing
no nothing
you know our national sport is rugby we
get 30 40 000 people at a stadium that's
happening at the moment
um and then i come in and i because i
kind of take on american politics
intravenously that's sort of what i do i
wake up every morning and check my phone
to see if donald trump's blown up the
top half of the world yet
um and i forget and then i watch a white
house briefing and i'm like [ __ ] me all
these people are wearing masks
and i'm like oh that's right there's
this thing going on outside the borders
of new zealand
that's not happening here and then when
i see that i kind of go
oh you know thanks to those who are
making the decisions yes jacinda are
doing but also
following the medical advice following
the who guidelines
and yeah i i'm i'm so lucky happy and
blessed to be living where i am right
now trust me and
because of that long-winded answer the
answer to your question is yes
because of cover that's why she's riding
so high right yeah no i feel the same
way in terms of
i mean things are better in new zealand
than they are in massachusetts
but if you look at the united states
things are pretty good in massachusetts
at least for now i i'm really interested
actually in new zealand because
at least in the united states there you
see sort of the
um idolizing of new zealand
for different reasons from left and
right so on the left
there's the understand or the idea of
new zealand as this kind of
um you know labour party left left
progressive
paradise with a great social safety net
and uh social services health care
education
etc on the libertarian right new zealand
is super popular as a place with
limited regulation and
geographic distance where you know rich
people are getting kind of
bug out bunkers very remote places where
they can go to if things if things go
bad i i don't know how
you know i don't know about the low
regulation actually being
accurate but maybe at least the
opportunity for privacy is something
that that is more accurate
um so i i find it interesting that for
different reasons left and right are
kind of interested in music
well there's certainly their perception
of so where i live in the bottom of the
south island if people want to look up
if people are watching from your end um
look up queenstown
queenstown is a location in the bottom
of the south island
up in the mountains it's kind of a kin
to aspen
so it's it's very wealthy it's very
expensive it's up in the mountains
there's snow in the winter there's
mountain biking in the summer beautiful
lakes
like like okay put it this way half of
lord of the rings was shot there
so that that's the environment we're
talking about um and they're currently
shooting the new
lord of the rings the amazon series up
there at the moment so it's it's
unbelievably naturally beautiful
incredibly expensive as well there are
many um
wealthy internationals who own places
out there however
it's interesting that you say
libertarians would like us i wouldn't
consider us to have low
regulations because you need to be
improved we have a government office
called the oio the office of
international
i can't remember anyway uh investment
officer anyway basically if you're
offshore and you want to spend money in
new zealand and buy property you have to
get approved by this government agency
so you can't just land buy a place and
set up a bunker
you have to be approved to buy it and
sometimes that's controversial peter
thiel has a place up in
um up in queenstown um you know what's
the name of the guy the the guy from
good morning america who got
uh during the me too moving got done
with the the door the lock in his door
and his office he pushed matt lauer yeah
matt lau's got a place up there was it
we don't even know who these people are
really he could walk down the street and
get no
no acknowledgement here whatsoever um
you know shania twain used to have a
place up there but she sold it
sometimes that comes with controversy
because we as new zealanders go why the
hell do they get to buy a sheep station
you know we should be keeping that
within our own boundaries so i don't see
regulations or i don't see us as being
kind of a soft and easy target for
wealthy people to come and live
but we are certainly removed and
isolated and safe and one of the reasons
we can do what we're doing with covert
is because we're
an island nation um you know so it's
easy
we do have covert in the country at the
moment but what's happening is
every person who lands currently
international visitors can't come to new
zealand only new zealanders can come
home
there's a few exceptions like the new
avatar is filming here at the moment
with james cameron
james cameron has a place up by
wellington um and they're filming up
there with peter jackson and weta
workshop so
that whole crew came in but that was for
a particular economic reason
but then when people land they get
isolated in a
government paid for hotel for two weeks
and that's the only place in the country
at the moment that has covert so there's
nothing
in the community it's only coming in on
planes and then being caught
at the border so the isolation does work
and with that isolation brings privacy
you mentioned privacy
but also with with our population brings
privacy
we're bigger um landmass than
uh great britain we have five million
people they have 60 million you know
there is
lots of space here it's easy to find
privacy
if you want to because because our
population density is very low
not to get totally off track but a
friend of mine and and his now a wife
spent like a summer in new zealand and
they actually
they they worked at baristas as baristas
and they claim
i want to fact check that the coffee
culture
in new zealand is extremely snobby and
strict which i love
it sounds great to me is that is that a
fact yeah totally like people
people we you know there's that old
saying when america sneezes the world
catches a cold
so america influences the world with
culture and with movies and with music
and you know the
america's fingers in every country every
western country especially
and we watch you know the idolizing of
things like starbucks and go oh god you
know that's not even
coffee it's disgusting sort of thing um
although there is starbucks here for
people who want it like my kids go to
starbucks because it's basically a
sugary drink
it's not coffee whereas we have like
here in dunedin we're a small city
comparative to the world you know 125
000 people in the city
there's probably i could probably think
of 10 individual
coffee roasters in this city who are
roasting their own beans
making their own mix and then roasting
them themselves and there's probably
50 to 100 really good coffee shops in
dunedin
that aren't just coffee shops it might
be coffee or cafes like the local
grocery store
i go to has a coffee machine and trained
baristas there and it's for fruit and
veggie
but there's a coffee machine in it and
they charge really low but it's like two
bucks for a
for a good barista cup of coffee so yeah
it's everywhere and it's really snobby
and uh you know if you're a bit like me
and you enjoy decaf sometimes you get
looked down on
but yeah it's a it's a great it's a
great apparently we have a great culture
of coffee
compare if you compare the coffee
culture to the rest of the world
i'm going to have to visit if only for
that alone i heard you wanted to leave
leave america i heard that you were
making noises about getting out in the
fall bro i thought you'd come down here
come pay us a visit i'll set you up i'll
find you a place down here and come and
broadcast out of new zealand
you know what's fascinating is so
the type of person i'm not part of the
let's move to canada movement that says
you know if trump is re-elected i'm
moving to canada sort of thing
by the way it's really hard to move to
canada so even if i wanted to i don't
know that i'd actually be able to but i
have i mean my you know
my family's here my house is here all
yeah et cetera
um but i have said that with the idea of
the virus
resurging in the fall and maybe it being
pretty ugly here until january february
if there was a good opportunity to go
somewhere that's doing well like
i was born in argentina it's a disaster
in argentina i'm not going to go to
argentina right now
i could go to israel but they're having
a problem with the virus so i'm not
going to go to israel like if i could go
somewhere that's doing well
and do my show for three or four months
i would consider it and the number one
place i got email well the two places i
got the most
emails from were australia and new
zealand saying
it's great here i know this person or
that person
i can get you a house i can get you
whatever you need i actually don't even
know the legality of
honestly like it sounds like you're
saying i couldn't even go to new zealand
no you could probably get a working visa
i mean we have a lot of people coming
through here
we do have restrictions not restrictions
on age but i think if you're under 35
you're it's sort of thought like you
might still be a student and you're
taking a gap year and you're doing a
working holiday
we have a lot of that i have i have
borders in my house uh two of them from
brazil
at the moment and they're here on that
kind of experience they're doing it i
don't
as long as our borders were open meaning
non-new zealanders were able to come or
if there was a good reason to it i don't
think it would be a problem getting a
you know six-month working visa because
that's what even though it's it's an
interesting dynamic actually thinking
about that
because if you're not actually taking a
job from new zealanders maybe you
wouldn't need a working visa
but probably the easiest way to do it is
to get a term work visa
holiday a working holiday is what they'd
call it
and and but right now i would just
wouldn't be allowed in because i'm not
from new zealand like only new
zealanders are being allowed in
i think that would be the case unless
there's special circumstances like the
crew of avatar obviously that's a
massive boost for our economy um i was i
did a podcast during the lockdown
uh with a poker pro from um
from las vegas and he wants to come down
we also do some really interesting
things in new zealand
um that because we are little and we're
at the bottom of the world
sometimes obviously tourism is a massive
part of what we do
uh we're we're quite heavily inundated
with
things like influencers i [ __ ] hate
that word but you know people who have
large large instagram accounts and stuff
and sit around and take photos of their
asses that sort of thing
um but because we're little it's good to
have
people come through here who then share
new zealand with the rest of the world
it's a good way of doing it
so you know for someone like you or for
someone in your kind of position that
could be a
that could be a case to put forward come
down here for three to six months and
say
you know along with my show i'm going to
xyz and get around the country and you
know yada yada perhaps i don't know
i don't know that's something to look at
that's actually something to look at but
yeah i mean
i'm not in the mindset of i'm trying to
abandon the united states or anything
like that
in fact on my show later this week i've
already recorded a segment
about like what would it take for me to
say i'm done with the united states at
this point and really it would take a
lot i mean this is why the idea that
taxing billionaires will get them to
leave the country
is is not a great argument because for
the most part
by the time people are most people by
the time they're billionaires
uh they're relatively well established
they have family where it is that they
are and
they're not you know they may own places
around the world but for the most part
people are where they are for a reason
yeah no i think um
we just had some regulation released
yesterday as to how we're going to start
to open our borders
and one of it comes down to who's paying
for these two-week stays
um i'm sort of of the opinion and this
hasn't happened that
we should open up our borders to
everybody but
no matter what you come into the country
for you have to do that two-week stand
down
and you have to pay for it yourself now
what that probably means is you would
get
a number of or maybe a a lot of high net
worth
individuals coming into the country to
go on holiday for
a year you know if you're a billionaire
and you want to get away from [ __ ] texas
or
or brazil or the uk or whatever at the
moment
and you can come on holiday in a place
that has got no community transmission
for a year why wouldn't you and that
would be great for the economy
they haven't done that yet um they've
they've kind of just said
they've made some um they're about to
start charging people
for their two weeks days under certain
conditions like if you leave the country
and go on holiday
when you come back you'll still have a
two-week stand down and you'll have to
pay for yourself whereas at the moment
they're saying
if you're repatriating yourself to stay
then the government pays rep so the
government spent something like 430
billion dollars
on people's stay in the country and
remember we are
5 million so what's that like 1 60th the
size
of america so multiply 4 billion by 60
and you'll get the equivalent of what
the americans would have spent if they'd
done the same thing
so yeah and of course i mean there's no
shortage of spending money here
but it's being spent in ways that are
seemingly
less logical in a lot of ways so clearly
the money is there
but a lot of strange things are being
done with it lately i was fascinated i
had dave rubin on a few weeks ago
as well and really yeah yeah yeah it was
it was fun
um actually sam cedar picked us up and
that was sort of the start of a few
connections through into the american
any show because because i explained i
did this the other week i had these uh
two young american girls on girls as
patronizing
women on who have done a song vote trump
though trump it's just
ridiculous well not ridiculous it's very
catchy actually so they're they're
they're trump i'm gonna have to see some
of these episodes it sounds like you
guys are really churning a lot of ideas
around that
uh uh and the thing that i realized is
the thing that it feels like is is
there is a sector of america that is
really ill-informed
and yes what happened with uh these
these girls the vote trump think is
they have a list of information
that they support trump on and they're
based on the promises he's kept and i
said to them what about all the promises
he hasn't kept
and of course that that's a google
search away in fact this website set up
to
show you know what trump hasn't kept
up to and including things like building
a wall and
the response was oh i don't know about
any of those i was like ah
that's really interesting and then with
dave i talked about how our
our and i love talking to americans
about healthcare because we have a
brilliant health care
system you know my my mom sadly two
years ago passed away of motor neuron
disease
spent three years basically with the
illness finished up with a
a a bed a bed from germany and a chair
from japan or something
and then a state i thought not a cent
went out of my parents bank balance you
know it was that was the way it is
and sam picked up on the sam cedar
picked up on this i didn't because i'm
not quite as
knowledgeable as to what obamacare is
but when i described what we did
to dave dave said he'd support that
and sam said i described obamacare
so it's it was it was that's interesting
because um i've had the exact same
conversation i don't want to turn this
into a being about dave rubin but the
last time
i spoke to dave rubin um via audiovisual
means was when he was on my program for
about an hour
and he had said he was against obamacare
but then he said what he would want is
abcd and described obamacare yeah it was
interesting that that was repeated on
your program i'm going to have to go
find them
yeah well i mean i'll continue the
length of it if you want bro um um
yeah so there's this there seems to be
this
um and i guess we all have our bubbles
you know that we're in
and that we mostly rely on i guess
and i spoke to these american haley and
camille with their names and i spoke to
them about it and i and i always use
this terrible analogy of
you know when you're sitting outside a
situation that's sometimes easy to see
and see what's going on
and i often talk about because i'm from
new zealand about the rugby field
being like your life so the field of get
play where all the players on that's my
life
and all the players on the field is part
of my life but sometimes when you're in
the ruck and you're
you know your head's down and you're and
you're in a scrum or something like that
you can't see as clearly as what's going
on out the back of the field
as someone sitting in the stand and i
used to use that analogy
to be like a counselor a counselor or
someone who sits in the stand they can
look down on the field of your life and
say what about this what about this i
think with america for some people
present company excluded obviously who
aren't well informed as to what's going
on in america
people on the outside looking in people
sitting in the stands going man this is
america
sometimes have a better um understanding
of what's happening in america than some
of these americans who are
ensconced in a fox news bubble or
you know or whatever bubble it is let's
not just pick on a right-wing bubble but
whatever bubble it is
um yeah and and so i consume everything
you know my fee brings everything up far
left news
you know independent stuff off the media
far right news even oen pops up
occasionally on my news feeds and
i keep an eye on it because i think it's
good to you know
you know the enemy is that the saying
yeah i mean i think it's good to have so
there's kind of two views on this
as an observer if you're observing the
culture and you're observing the
political
uh spectrum and you're trying to
understand what are the sort of limits
of the debate that are taking place
it's really good to be consuming and
looking at a wide spectrum of things
the problem of course is people who are
less savvy when it comes to media
literacy
and critical thinking and the risk is
like when i see oan it's interesting to
me
because i'm understanding the place that
it has as
an even more right-wing and less
professional
alternative to fox news which has sort
of become
something for donald trump to promote
when he wants to criticize fox news
it's more conspiratorial it's even less
fact
you know like i understand its role and
its place on the spectrum
the problem is that you get folks who
they come across it in their feed
and they um sort of accept it
with the same understanding as if it
were the washington post
and then that's how you end up with
people that seem to be
in a fantasy world and believing things
not based in fact so that's the danger
of it
or one step worse than that they take it
more seriously than washington post
because the washington post
was taken by jeff bezos who's the devil
incarnate and a left-wing lunatic
of course which nothing could be further
from the truth
yeah yeah so you're talking about people
who want politically or
media savvy enough to understand what
they're actually seeing
yeah no i used to i worked in talkback
for 10 12 years here in new zealand um
we've really only got one talkback
station it's the biggest radio station
in new zealand
um and i used to say i watch fox news a
lot
i don't watch it as a source of news i
watch it more for entertainment but i do
watch it a lot
because that's about the level although
it's interesting a recent time seeing
more and more of their hosts
on occasion starting to call out trump
and i wonder if that's simply because
they know trump's not going to be in
after the next election
and they need access to buy it and if
they're not fair to buy it now
they may not have it yeah i think
there's a scatter shot approach being
taken on fox news where they want to
have examples of everything that they
can point to
and it's almost like having an audio
mixer with a bunch of things
set to two so that you know if you need
to turn
something up to four you can and so
that's i think why you're seeing
donald trump very happy with some of the
stuff that's on fox news
and then at the same time attacking some
of the the broadcasters and programs on
twitter that are on fox news
i think that's essentially what's going
on i mean it's just a business you know
and
fox news is decidedly right-wing but
they're not married to trump
and early in the republican primary even
in 2015 before 2016 before it was clear
trump would be the nominee
fox was very anti-trump and i think had
they known he was going to be the
nominee
they would have probably been more
favorable to him from the beginning
and it's it's really simply a business
yeah no i think i saw you or heard you
on on rogan's podcast talking about
it's more of a the left versus right
thing is more of a commercial entity
first
a a a business is about making money
first
and if they can make money uh you know
uh being more attractive to the left
then they will will be more attractive
to the right they will but
the dollar is the thing everyone's
chasing as opposed to a political
ideology and i think that's a really
yeah i mean when fox news started in
1996 it started because of a market
opportunity
it started with the growing idea that
the media was left-wing that corporate
media was left-wing we can debate to
what degree that's true i think it's
more of a corporatist centrist bias but
but it doesn't matter
the idea that they could repeat that the
media is left-wing
created the market opportunity and
that was the genesis of fox news had
that not had there not been a market
opportunity
the fact that right-wing people would
love to do right-wing muse would have
not been enough to get fox news going it
was the financial piece that made it
possible
following on from fox news starting was
that when
conservative talks started to get bigger
as well like i'm thinking of the rush
limbaugh's of this world or were they
always that sort of
big influencer and then fox news
followed them
fox news really followed them there's an
interesting a very important book
which may be out of print called waves
of rancor which
actually goes back far earlier than fox
news
to the genesis of talk radio and how it
was dominated by the right and it's it's
actually a structural explanation
for why um there was the
um it was radio stations benefiting from
lower
from less regulation under the fcc
that sort of created a
to where if you were running a radio
station you were
better off with lower regulation which
also meant you were probably more likely
to be on the political right
which is how talk radio started with
right-wing
political content a lot of
religious-based content in fact
a lot of religious based content content
predated the straight up political
content on
on talk radio in the united states so
that definitely predates fox news by
many decades
it's one of the things that's always
fascinated me and confused me about
america is the whole um conservative
evangelical world
i it's a bizarre it used to be one
and it used to be one of my favorite
talk topics i used to
i used to talk i used to love talking
politics and religion
and um you know issues around new
zealand as well when i was doing talk
back it's still sort of what my
event is now but you know not to
reference this podcast i did a few weeks
ago but
finally getting to talk to it was like i
got to my um perfect storm they were
um young which you wouldn't think
necessarily are republican voters
they were women who you didn't think
would be supporting trump they were
christians and they were trump
supporters and i was just like holy crap
this is the this is the gold mine of
people i've always wanted to talk to to
try and figure it out i still am no
clearer at the end of it although
i think to be honest with you the the
abortion issue
seems to be the be all and end all
amongst those conservative
christians that pardon the pun but
trump's everything else as long as they
say they're pro-life everything else
goes out the window
no matter what but it's a it's a surreal
and bizarre thing
it's changed a bit though so there's a
couple things that have been going on
one is that since since roe v wade which
here in the united states is sort of
like the landmark
abortion related legislation or
framework
since roe v wade support for abortion
being legal in most cases is the highest
it's ever been right now
so that's been a shift and that has made
abortion a little bit less
of a wedge with which to either divide
people or raise money although certainly
in the evangelical circles it's still
very very important but the other thing
that's gone on is
so prior to trump i would have divided
the american right into sort of three
main groups
one is the sort of mitt romney john
kasich
type um low tax pro business type
republicans who they might be socially
conservative but
by by coincidence but it's less their
their main
avenue of evangelizing for their views
you then have the evangelical religious
conservatives or i guess we would say
religious conservatives who are mostly
evangelical christians although it
includes
conservative catholics as well and other
sects that's the second piece
and then the third piece was these kind
of tea party
liberty and freedom more
libertarian-minded folks
so that those were the three big pieces
in the trump era
there's been this fourth group which
seems to not care
at all about policy they i mean okay if
trump says he's against abortion
now at you know when he was 68 he said
i'm now against abortion
they believe it and i guess they're fine
with it but if he weren't against
abortion
it would it would be okay and trump's
never really been bothered by a gay
marriage
and that's fine although if he was
against gay marriage that would be great
too it's more about
angering the left doing the opposite of
what the left wants
and supporting sort of like the cult of
personality
and that is now like a pretty important
fourth
wing of the american right and once
trump is gone whenever that is it'll be
interesting to see whether that remains
or sort of fades away
well it's interesting you mentioned the
tea party they they kind of got
absorbed pretty quickly into the
republicans
because the other thing it seems that
and talked about our political system
being mixed member proportional
we sort of have what
america has it's just we have them in
separate parties
so some of our centrist party mps and i
think there's about seven of them in
that particle new zealand first
would be more on the left some would be
more on the right they could be split
and they could go either side
and obviously our far right there's only
one mp in that party called x
he could become a part of the national
party which is our main part of the year
and our far left quite unquote far left
green party
could be could go and then you'd have
just two parties and i wonder
and i know this will never happen it's
more of a i don't know
a mind game to play but it seems that if
your
far right republicans broke off and
formed a tea party
and your far left progressive broke off
and formed a progressive party
then everyone would actually fit more
naturally as to where they their
ideologies are
and then perhaps you would get the two
parties joining after the election
to form a majority but oh you don't no
that's not right is it but you just have
four you'd have sorry you'd have four
presidential candidates to vote for four
main ones you'd have the progressive
candidate the left candidate the right
candidate
and the far right candidate and that
would be how you get your
your representation of everybody yeah i
mean it with our current voting system
of course it's just whoever
received the plurality would be that
that that would essentially be it
and then in the house of representatives
where there's 435 seats in some
districts
one of these other parties might be able
to win some seats but
you know this gets to really thinking
about whether the first pass the post
voting system we have is the one that
best
serves a diversity of ideas i think it's
probably not to be perfectly frank and
i've talked a lot about that
um but it's a it's a um
you you know the tea party is
interesting because
they now i believe in the house of
representatives
there's 23 tea party caucus
members who are republic they're all
republicans yeah there's this
caucus which is not of any real
significance other than they
you know may work on legislation
together or agree to support or not
support legislation although as a group
um
they they were just absorbed into the
republican party
the don't tread on me ideology of the
tea party
was sort of accepted a little bit more
into the republican party and there's no
more really distinct
ideology other than this caucus it could
have gone a different way
which is that there could have been a
more wholesale rejection of tea party
ideology in the subsequent election
which there was not and as you say it's
sort of been accepted and absorbed
i think the one of the things that i
like i'm sharing with americans often
and it blows some of their brain
especially if they're conservative
is the evidence that america is a
left-wing country
um and the the the information all the
the
the research that i cite is very simple
i think it's since um clinton
the republicans have only won the
popular vote once and that was george w
bush's second term
after after 9 11. other than that every
other election
more people have voted for the left than
the right now to me
when you say talk about first pass
opposed to that is evidence of how
unfair the system is
and how actually you know america is
founded on these ideals and freedoms and
fairnesses and one man one vote it's not
it's not the case
because if it was one person one vote
and your vote actually mattered then
since 1994 there would have been a
left-wing government
for that whole time bar one year
obviously sliding doors
you know we can't say that for sure but
i think that's fairly evidence
evident that america is a left more
a more left-leaning country and i'll
probably go one step further and say
most western countries are probably more
left-leaning
in general and the problem is the left
is typically more apathetic and the
right are better organizers and that's
actually what makes the
election in whatever western country
more of a battle as opposed to where the
population sits
so in terms of generally the left being
more apathetic
i don't know i mean what like what i can
speak to would be
in the united states first of all on
issues the country has moved left
right so as i mentioned before support
for abortion being legal in most cases
higher than ever support for
same-sex marriage higher than ever um
support for the government should
provide
some level of health care for everybody
regardless of ability to pay
higher very very high exactly what
what mode it takes is certainly up for
debate and so
yes on the issues i think you're
absolutely right the reason
the reasons that the right continues to
do well are as you mentioned
the electoral college despite losing a
number of popular vote elections
the electoral college has bailed out
republicans um
that's one reason number two at this in
the united states at the state and local
level the republican party is
absolutely better at organizing and they
understand you know taking over school
boards taking over boards at state
boards of education
uh state houses it's starting to turn a
little bit what we're seeing in virginia
is sort of reassuring
georgia and texas are starting to
certainly look less overtly red so
that's another reason republicans do
well
um and the the other aspect of it is
the republican party has openly tried to
suppress the vote in their favor from
multiple election cycles at this point
and you don't have to take my word for
it look at the video of mike
turzai admitting it look at trump saying
you know if you do all of this if if so
many more people vote republicans will
never win again
and so this is a whole other story but
everything from voter registration
purges
reducing voting locations in
disproportionately
left-leaning areas it's a playbook and
it's a whole
topic on its own but that skews the
results when i completely agree with you
on the issues the u.s is as left as it
has been in a very long time
do you think that is because attitudes
are changing
uh or do you think it's because of
attrition i mean everyone has always
talked about for the last 10 or 15 years
oh you know when those old people die
off
you know the the world will be a
different place where do you place that
shift to the left
so the there's this sometimes people in
the us will say
people get more conservative as they get
older there's not actually the evidence
i've seen of that the evidence i've seen
is that at any given time at
any given point in time the older folks
are more conservative than the younger
folks so
it's not that a 50 year old by the time
they're 60 is more likely to be
conservative it's that
in 2020 the 50 year olds are likely to
be
more liberal than the 60 year old so in
a sense that sort of goes to your
attrition idea which is
subsequent generations tend to be more
to the left
now there's groups in the united states
like turning point usa and others who
want to make the case that there's a
resurgence of the young
rights i don't really think so
uh because when you poll a lot of these
people you know they may
show up at a trump event and they may be
able
able to articulate some policy ideas
that sort of line up with
with trump-ism but the idea of young
people is conservative in the
traditional sense i don't think has been
demonstrated
and i think that it's hard to get a good
read on it right now because of the cult
of trumpism
and hopefully once that goes away a lot
of those people are going to realize
you know the the pre-trump republican
party conservatism is not really for me
it's a guess but i'm hoping that that
happens
well and also i think that what you hear
in the media as often as
as we all know um the five percent on
either side
the five percent extremists on the other
side get you know 90 of the air time
so what we're what we're seeing and
hearing of the resurgence of the young
conservative
might be there five percent on the far
end but then there's another 45
that sits in that conservative side that
isn't young at all
i mean you look at just another question
about it yeah you look at the numbers of
uh of age of people who watch fox news
that kind of stuff and it's probably i
don't know is it up to 80 yet well soon
last i saw it was over 65 the average
age
yeah the demographics of the typical fox
news viewers skew quite old now that
being said
it's not like cnn and msnbc are overrun
over overrun with a young audience but
it's certainly younger i think the
concern more
more recently is these um sort of filter
bubble
recommendation algorithm echo chambers
that the younger people can fall into
on youtube for example where uh you know
people have called into my show and they
say you know i really cared about video
games
and video games on youtube ended up with
me being recommended a right-wing gamer
which led me to ben shapiro and jordan
peterson
and next thing i know i'm a men's rights
activist like that's a caricature
of it yeah but that is a story that
is is a relevant one and so that i think
is more important
than fox news or rush limbaugh at this
point at least for the younger
generation
well then you get the flip side of it as
well you get that fantastic trolling
from
south korea and tick tockers with you
know donald trump's uh campaign
his rally and tulsa who he thought he
was gonna have a million people and they
got six thousand so
i guess they're both doing it aren't
they both the left and the right are
finding ways to use new technology but
it's not
it's not the dnc or the rnc that's doing
it it's
i hate to use the term grass roots but
it's young people going hey here's a
good idea it's them
basically figuring out how to use the
technology to speak to their people and
i think brilliant
brilliant yes although a lot of it is
not grassroots i mean a lot of the stuff
that's happening on the right anyway and
this is like
to their credit i mean i'm not i i said
politically i don't like it
but strategically they're doing
something that the left is not doing
which is
the left doesn't really have these
established paths
where they will sort of help
on campus politically outspoken people
build coalitions and support and pour
money into it
the left doesn't have widespread
you know trainings of teaching people
just
out of college messaging and how to
communicate left id the right has all of
this stuff
and they fund it so when you look at
something like turning point usa
it's heavily funded by legacy right-wing
groups and rich people but it looks as
though
to some people it looks as though it's
grassroots and you know
good for them in the sense that it's
working although i think the effects on
the country are disastrous
how long do you think it's going to be
until tv is finally dead i mean you talk
about who's watching tv the older people
i mean like people like yourselves and
if you look across the political
spectrum
you know there's you there's the young
turks there's the karl kalinskis there's
the stephen crowders there's the
however it is across the spectrum are
already sort of eating up certainly so
much of that younger audience
when is when is what you're doing and
i guess your your fellow independent
media groups
doing when is that going to be the the
first source of news for everybody
not just perhaps you know gen x and
below i think it will mostly depend on
the blending of cable tv
as a service and internet access as a
service and it's sort of starting to
happen
you know early in the broadband
revolution it was like okay
you've got your cable tv and here are
your channels and then you have your
internet service
over time it started to get blended in
that
you can hook up your internet to the tv
without really having cable and get
a youtube app on the television and
that's sort of starting
starting to blend yeah so i think it'll
be driven mostly by
technology um you know in in cars for
example
the reason i've not listened to the
regular radio in
eight years or something like that is
because i've had
serious satellite radio yep and i can
plug my phone in and get spotify
or whatever and so now car radio is
really
a bunch of different things and i think
technological change will continue to
drive that
but i don't think traditional television
is going to go away anytime soon we'll
probably
just see the balance continue to shift
yeah
yeah no it's it's fascinating i'm i'm
wondering we're a bit different here
because we're so much smaller
we have sort of only two major news
outlets on television
two national television so when the
covet happened we were having daily
briefings at one o'clock every day
and i think the number of people
watching on tv
outstrip the number of people watching
on the internet and i wonder if that's
part of
economies of scale everyone had a tv not
everyone had like we've got very good
broadband here in dunedin we're
i'm on a gig line which is which is good
for new zealand and good
on a world comparison but still not
everyone's got that but everyone does
have
a tv hey um we're coming up to an hour
so
time has flown by having a chat with you
i can keep going forever
anything else you want to leave our our
our people with and your people with at
the same time
uh yes if you have uh offers for me to
come to new zealand let me know
and uh no i mean it's always been a
place that's high on my list you know at
one point
the longest flight in the world i
believe was from my birth city of buenos
aires
to auckland at one point i believe that
flight has not existed
at this point for a little while and uh
i i don't know if it will come back but
new zealand has been an interesting
place to me for a long time and i would
i would love to visit
sooner than later and whether i shack up
for six months and do my show
avoiding the virus or whether it's just
you know a vacation
sometime down the line i seems like a
fascinating place and i would love to
visit well i do know that
uh of recent times probably not
operating at the moment there was a new
route put in from chicago to
auckland direct so that was put in
fairly recently sorry
if an americans that would be a route a
new route
we'd say route just to make sure that's
clear i was funny i was doing um i was
doing a sponsor last night
and uh you know we say xyz
whereas americans say xyz so where dot
co dot nz
but i repeated it just in case anyone
was tuning in dot co dot nz for the
website just in case there was an
american watch i think that's smart so
anyone knew
and then i and then i unfortunately
mocked the american language so probably
i turned a bunch of people off
not smart it's conceivably possible that
somebody was uh
very fragile in that moment and did not
like your pronunciation of letters
true david peckman thanks for joining us
dude it's been it's been a blast and
look
uh jacinda offered it to um to stephen
colbert
i'll offer it to you when you get to new
zealand i'll pick you up from the
airport it won't be a problem
please and then we'll have i'm sure the
best cappuccino
be safe in massachusetts brother thank
you so much
you